SPEAKER 1: Creating an
ML model in a notebook
can be quick and
straightforward,
but when you need
to expand your ML
workflow to be
sustainable and scalable,
things can get more complex.
In previous videos, we've
talked about pipelines and how
you can create,
manage, and reproduce
your workflows at a high level.
Let's break it down by
walking through a model
that we'll later use in
a key Kubeflow Pipeline.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Today, we'll go through the
details of a sample ML model.
You can check out other Kubeflow
samples in the link below.
First, set up a notebook
server running on Kubeflow.
If you need a refresher,
check out our previous videos
on how to do that.
Next, clone the GitHub
repo linked below
and access the Chicago
Crimes Research notebook.
This notebook walks
through a model
that we'll use as a part
of a Kubeflow Pipeline
in the next video.
So let's walk through how
the model actually works.
The model uses Chicago
daily crimes data
to forecast how many
crimes are expected
to be reported the next day
based on how many were reported
over the previous days.
Once the dependencies
are installed,
the first step is to query
the data table sitting
in a bigquery for
daily crimes over time,
then download it into
our in Jupyter Notebook.
Next, you can visualize the
data as a line plot named
Daily Crime Reports
to give you an idea
of the actual values over time.
To prepare the data
for a model, you
need to pre-process the data.
Since this is a
sequence model, you
need to split data sequentially
to avoid potential bias.
With time-based data,
you want to make
sure you're not feeding the
model data that happened
after the prediction window.
Then, define the
percent of data you
should use for
your training, 80%,
and the number of
observations used to predict
the next observation.
Our window size is seven.
In other words, you'll be using
the prior seven days' worth
of data to predict the
next day's crime count.
When we pre-process
the data, we'll
split it up into the training
and evaluation data sets
and then normalize
the data to avoid
the influence of any outliers.
In order to begin
training our model,
you need to reformat
our training data set.
This generates an
input function that
specifies features and
labels, whether to shuffle
the data, number of
epochs, and batch size.
The resulting data set
can be fed directly
to the model for
training or evaluation.
Then, create a
model for regression
which returns a compile
model, an object that we'll
use to train.
Now you can begin
training and evaluation
by passing in the
training data set,
validation data set, and finally
train the model using those.
It returns the trained model.
Once you specify batch size,
learning rate, and number
of epochs, you can run the
train and evaluate function
to get the final model.
To evaluate the model,
take the trained model
and feed it the other
20% of evaluation data.
Finally, you can plot the
model's prediction outcome
and compare it to
the actual accounts.
Looking pretty good.
In the next video, we're
going to take this model
and create an ML application
using Kubeflow Pipelines.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]